the fastest way to absorb news is a
revolutionary app called newsreels i use
it all the time to quickly catch up on
news by scrolling through the reels page
similar to an instagram feed you can
read any story as quickly summarized
bullet points click the link below to
use newsreels for free
now i i want to talk about kind of the
sideshow there there's always with every
real story and the situation in del rio
texas with the haitian migrants is a
very real story joe biden is not uh
putting forth a sort of coherent package
of what it is that should happen and
that needs to be done
but there's always a side show and the
side show here is fox news reporter
peter ducey
with a bizarre gotcha attempt with jen
saki the white house press secretary
yesterday focusing on
has joe biden been to the border in his
life that's the question
this is just so pathetic and the problem
with this is that it generates the idea
that these are sort of like valid
questions and the right way to hold the
administration accountable this is just
gutter trash okay let's take a look at
the video has president biden ever been
to the southern border
in his life yes i will have to get look
back in my history books and check the
times he's been to the southern we have
been looking all morning and we cannot
find any record of him visiting the
border as president vice president
senator or even as a concerned citizen
why would that be
i can check and see when the last time
or when he may have been but but tell me
more about why you're asking because
this is a president who makes a point
when there are disasters in this country
like a wildfire or
a hurricane to go and see for himself
firsthand what the needs are of the
local community so that he can have an
informed
pov to make policy why doesn't he do
that why doesn't he go down to del rio
texas and see what's going on well first
of all peter i think the situation at
the border is the result of a broken
system and the president certainly
relies on his experience so whether it
was the work he did to address root
causes as vice president
his efforts when he was in the senate to
support comprehensive immigration reform
a steps that at a time were being done
and work toward in a bipartisan way
something that uh certainly we think
should be the case today
so you know the answer from gensake is
okay
but
there are real questions here as we
discussed in the last segment uh you're
opposed to the treatment of the migrants
but at the same time you're not really
improving the sanitation and food
situation but at the same time these are
at least for now people who are here
illegally but at the same time even
though you want to be more humane you're
you know
expelling people
without any real uh analysis of the
situation and it's not really clear what
solution you're proposing and biden's
approval is declining there's a real
situation here that could develop into a
very significant drag for joe biden
but whether biden has been to the border
is really completely irrelevant and it
also bears mentioning i guess
that even
just going to a location
when you're a president
doesn't necessarily really do much i
mean remember when after the uh
hurricanes and i think it was um i think
it was 2017 when donald trump went to
puerto rico oh wow he went wow that's
great
he shot rolls of paper towels like
basketballs
and appeared completely insensitive and
arguably made things worse
by just bringing his whole entourage and
and uh team and you know the entire
apparatus that travels with the
president to a place that was trying to
recover still didn't have power back on
in many places etc so merely going is no
big victory and unfortunately
this counts as like valid journalism
among many on the right this is they see
peter ducey
uh ask his questions with his you know
up speak and bizarre delivery
um and they say wow
he really exposed this administration no
he really didn't
uh and particularly in this situation
this is not a natural you know a natural
disaster where you go and tour damage
and and console victims uh this is a
this is an immigration situation with
complex legal circumstances
what would even be the point of joe
biden going down there like aside from
whether in general a president needs to
go somewhere in order to properly deal
with the situation in this particular
case it seems joe biden going down there
would it would it at minimum add nothing
and that worse possibly even make the
situation more complicated so it's
another failed gotcha but sadly in this
country given the lack of you know
sort of awareness that so many people
have about what are the important
political questions and how do we figure
out problems in in society and in
government
um this is this is considered really
powerful journalism and that's probably
uh why fox news keeps peter ducey in the
white house press briefing room what do
you think needs to happen
um on the border with this particular
situation find me on twitter deepakman
and let me know